foreign
about this call um no pun intended
because uh John's calling from New
Orleans but this is a follow-up call to
a call we had is about seven or eight
months ago
is that right August but August okay
um
a call that was Haunting and
heartbreaking
um and we're gonna link to the original
call in the show notes
um fantastic but then John's calling
with an update what's up man
hey Dr John how you doing today I'm
doing great man how are you
uh we are we're surviving uh we're doing
we're doing good all things considered
very cool man all right so
um I've heard you've got an update call
so walk us through well I'm gonna do a
quick recap and you tell me if I've got
it or not so
um your daughter got sick it looked like
it was E coli and in short fashion her
system started shutting down and the
folks at the hospital pulled you in the
side room that I've been in too many
times and with families and they said
hey you've got some really hard
decisions to make
and you guys decided hey we want to
transfer out of this hospital and go get
a second opinion and they fought you on
it but eventually they let you do it and
they took you to another hospital and
they were like hey don't give up on this
little girl yet
um we think she's gonna be okay
um is that is that a good summary
summary
yeah
um it's a pretty accurate there okay um
correct and we we transferred
um you know to the Children's Hospital
here in New Orleans and our whole world
um got flipped back upside down again
but in a in a better way and um
Scarlett started recovering and I think
when we spoke uh last time I was on like
day 38 of what ended up being a 75-day
hospitals day and
um
Against All Odds
um this little girl who we were told
would never walk never talk
um you know have very limited life uh
capabilities if if she survived
legitimately walked out the front door
of the hospital yeah dude that's
incredible man
carrying balloons everyone clapping and
cheering for it was
um
she made a lot of really really smart
people
um looked um
as kids usually do right
oh my gosh
um I mean we're still living in it we're
living in a different uh in a different
uh reality now yeah but um so what
limitations does she have now
I'm sorry say that again what
limitations does she have now or she is
she up and Adam running around
uh she's up and on it running around
um she has some uh hyper uh flexation of
her left knee and some uh she postures
with her left arm she's on a feeding
tube
um you know we still have we still have
some stuff she goes to about 45
different appointments a month between
physical therapy occupational therapy
speech feeding and seeing all the
specialists
um so she's a very busy little
two-year-old are you seeing some
progress
um oh yeah uh she's jumping off the
couch and doing all the stuff the
two-year-old's supposed to do and and
scaring us and all the the normal ways
now good hope she scares you all to
death not as bad as she did the first
time but the regular the regular way
right good good good correct well dude
you like as I told you last time as the
dad of a little girl man like you
you've lifted my spirits and I'm really
grateful that you called back is uh is
there anything I can help you with like
what's going on in the world now
oh yeah
um you know we had a fantastic support
system while we were in the hospital and
we got home and and you know everyone
went back to their
um to their normal lives and routines
and you know my wife and I we found
ourselves uh you know living in a
different in a different uh reality that
most people don't understand
and you know now that we're six seven
months out of being out of the hospital
we're trying to grieve and process and
and move forward
um in our new reality
and what it sounds like we've you know
we've been seeing some counselors and
who has been described is that me and my
wife we've landed in two different
places in our grief
and the handling of our new reality
so I'm looking for advice on how we can
both work on ourselves which has been
painfully hard to do so that we can get
back to the same place all while
managing those 45 appointments
um all the feeding issues running a
household and equally as important
giving proper care and attention to
um her big sister oh man yeah that's a
that's a big one I'm gonna give you a
really unconventional probably not PC
answer is that okay
go for it I'm almost positive that none
of your therapists are going to give you
this answer
and it's something
um I've just been over the last couple
years traveling the country talking to
people about trauma and about with
coming back from some of these things
and
here's a couple of really important
things number one you gotta get rid of
the just get back to language
there is no just get back to
what was is completely gone
and so often we spend so much energy
trying to get back to the way things
were that
um and you're experiencing this and I'm
trying to read between the lines here
but these kind of situations often break
up couples simply because they grieve
differently and one person is like how
can you be moving on and laughing and
carrying on and the other person is like
how can you stay mired in this and
continue to relive it and relive it am I
on the right page
yes okay and eventually somebody says
I've got to go find joy in my life and
eventually somebody says I've got to
find somebody who understands the hell
I'm in and both of them end up you know
a thousand miles apart from each other
and so and even though they may be
sharing the same bed sitting on the same
couch right and so
you have to get rid of any sort of
comparison think of your old self as
your neighbors you got a different life
man there's there's no no benefit to
comparing what was the only thing and
this can actually be fun and exciting in
a way to bring people together is to
decide what are we going to build moving
forward what do we want this to look
like that's number one is we have to
decide we're going to build something
new not just get through the next month
and the next month or the next month and
try to get back to some semblance of
normalcy normal's over the second thing
and this is where people are going to
disagree with me and I don't care I'm
right is
I don't think that married couples after
the first and
maybe a first couple of months of trauma
healing
if a couple is going to make a go of
creating a new life together the healing
has to be done together
so after the initial here's how I'm
processing this trauma here's how I'm
processing this trauma and this is
bringing up this stuff in my life and
this is bringing up my life a lack of
control and all that great you gotta
process these things alone but the
majority of the work the bulk of the
work has to be done
teaching two people okay I know you feel
like the world's coming to an end every
time you open your eyes it's not
so you have to choose to get up and do
hard things I go for a walk and exercise
and have sex again and watch funny
movies again and you over here who's
just trying to run and be like it's all
going to be great and Pretend This Never
Happened you've got to spend some time
grieving on a regular basis and that
might look like journaling and that
might look like a weekly breakfast where
you say the words I'm really scared
about and you answer right and the goal
is
both people have to do hard things
creating a new tomorrow together
and I think the only way you can do that
in y'all situation is to do couples
counseling with the intent of we're
building something new together we're
letting the old thing go
tell me where how does that how does
that hit you
um it hits pretty pretty close to home
here okay
um I think that's something that we're
we're maybe just starting to do with the
couple's counseling okay
um you know we're only a couple sessions
in
um and you know I've been seeing
therapists which is a challenge in
season trying to see therapists which is
also a challenge and but getting us
together has been difficult
I would at this point unless there's
some some psychiatric issues meaning one
of y'all's on meds now and one of y'all
seeing a psychiatrist like absent that
I would if I'm in your shoes and again
I'm talking to you now just as a dad a
little girl and a guy who's married
I I would spend the bulk of my energy on
how did me and my wife create something
new together
and not spend all these sessions like
well he's not doing this and she's keeps
doing this that's just not productive
it's just gonna send you on a loop right
and the more you stay on that Loop the
more maybe your optimism and you are
look how bright everything is
serves as the same defense mechanism
that she might have which is this could
happen again this could happen again
this could happen again and you end up
going nowhere right you end up going
nowhere and so getting together and
saying okay we're gonna spin the and
maybe you tell your couple's counselor
here's what our goals are our goals are
to build something completely new
because everything we knew blew up we
almost lost our precious daughter
and now we don't trust the world we walk
in We Are catastrophizing Everything one
of us can't put the news down one of us
can't quit pretending that it's all
going to be Rosy and great I'm tired of
driving and I don't have anyone I can
say those things to right so how do we
build that relationship together moving
forward
foreign I would be real intentional with
your therapist and if your therapist
says well you know we need to go back to
it may not be the right therapist for
you right now
all right I'm I'm trying to jot notes
because we need to be very intentional
here here's what we'll do I'm going to
send you a raw link to this an unedited
link to this right after the show I'll
just we'll just send it to you okay and
um it'll probably be a little bit
different that Sarah and the editing
team make me sound a lot better after
the show than uh during the show but
that way you can have some of these
notes you can take into the counselor
and I'd also if if your wife is up for
it I think it's worth having this
conversation with her
absolutely and I've I had it with my
wife like uh and I've told talk about on
the show like where I told her man like
man I just thought after you got
pregnant like okay nine months and then
I get my wife back my crazy fun wife and
then I realized after Hank was born like
okay maybe nine more months and then
things go back to normal and I didn't I
never realized oh things never go back
to normal everything's different now
everything's different and then we had
Josephine everything's different we had
all these miscarriages everything's
different we got a new job everything's
different so the the adventure of life
now is not trying to hold on to what was
but it's creating a rhythm where we can
create something new at the drop of a
hat because that's how the world works
foreign
extremely used to our new reality or
it's
um you know we've we've made a lot of
progress with her and we're starting to
get to the point where I think that we
can we're in a place where we might be
able to try to build something new like
you're saying that's awesome can I tell
you this
it's okay to be really annoyed by all
the appointments
a lot it can be it's okay to be really
pissed off at all those bills that start
coming in
and it can be really mad when your
daughter's jumping off a couch and it
kind of pulls the feeding tube and then
she cries and you've told her and you
feel guilty for yelling at a kid that
almost died like all that's okay
like you're not a bad dad
for being pissed off you're not a bad
dad for your wife coming home so
exhausted because she went to seven
appointments this today and you're
trying to work a full-time job and be a
dad to your other kid
and you're just exhausted and you're
just mad at everybody oh that's okay man
thank you okay and it's okay for her too
and here's a simple thing you can do
with the other daughter and then I'll
let you go
um it's as simple as do you drive her to
school how does she get to school
uh we live close enough we walk okay
um it may be worth having a special day
once a week where you just drive her and
you get some cheap cheesy breakfast
somewhere
and she has special I mean it can be as
little as 30 to 45 minutes a week a very
special check-in time with Dad and if
Mom's available
um she can rotate but just a here's my
special moment and another thing I would
do is I would put a small spiral
notebook or take her out somewhere and
let her buy a real fancy notebook and
you put it on her bed and you write
notes back and forth to one another and
when she gets done writing a note she
puts it on your bed and then you read it
at night and then you write back to her
but it will be your secret private thing
that nobody else gets to touch nobody
else gets to mess with that sister can't
ruin and screw everything up
um it's just a special Channel between
dad and mom and their their daughter and
it sounds very minute and very small
these are big big things do a little six
and seven year old
that sounds amazing and yeah she's six
years old so yeah dude she's writing it
she's writing it
um another thing is to always let her
feel a part of things whenever possible
so say things like
um what are some things we can do to
help your sister today or to your your
this baby of yours here at the house
um and giving some ownership and
responsibility age appropriate of course
can really add to like a young kid can
walk really tall and I've loved seeing
I've worked with special needs kids for
my whole career and I love seeing their
brothers and sisters because a lot of
them are gangsters they're there
gangsters man because they're used to
hey you you're gonna give access to my
to my brother you're gonna let my sister
have the appropriate resources and they
become real great Advocates and it's a
fine line because you don't want them
doing adult work you don't want them
responsible for their brother and sister
that's a burden they can't carry but
when they have a little bit of of
support and a little bit of of hey
you're in this too this is your brother
and sister Anne man some kids will take
that and run with it and it's a great
gift it's a great gift
um but find those little moments where
you can look that little girl
six-year-old in the eye and say Oh Daddy
still sees you too
daddy sees you and every day I thank God
that I get to be your dad
oh man it's awesome that gets me Ah
that's one of my favorite things in the
world all right brother John hey call
anytime
um keep us updated I think on how things
are going and I'd love to hear about how
you're uh marriage counseling works out
when you come in with some notes to your
therapist and say hey here's what we
want to do here's where we want to go
thank you so much for the call my
brother I'm so grateful your daughter's
doing awesome